Wouldn't it be good for everyone to do the Dutch test?
No, I mean what first of all
You have to separate the sexants. So I don't typically recommend the Dutch test for men
Unless they have extreme fatigue and that's what they're struggling with some of my live patients. I'll recommend the Dutch test if they're a male
But for a cancer patient, typically I don't recommend the Dutch test. It's not going to give us information that we're going to need to make changes
For women, it's a different story fluctuations in hormones affect multiple organs and cause multiple symptoms
Whether you have cancer or not
so but
Honestly, this question would it be good for every woman to do the Dutch test? Well, it depends on
You know if they have symptoms. So if you have a let's say a symptomatic 25-year-old
They're not having issues with their periods. They're not having you know emotional breakdown or symptoms or high-formal PMS or anything like that
I'd say you don't need to but if you are having any of those things then yes, you should at least explore the
The possible imbalance of hormones as positive factor of a symptomatic patient. That's a female
So then getting the Dutch test would be in order
What the person let's say I have cancer and I don't have any symptoms
But I do have cancer a female should I do the Dutch test? Well, it depends on what type of cancer you have
But they have a hormone driven cancer than yes, you don't have a hormone driven cancer than no
It also depends on some other factors to you to take it
You know, the everybody doesn't need to do a test if you're not having any issues. I'd say my cancers, you know
You know
Decreased or I feel like a bit of state of remission that I don't know that we need to do that
But if you feel like the cancer's growing or trying to get a hold of it and it is a horrible driven cancer then yes, that would be in order